I always tell Tiff if you ever hit me
like I have I won't hit I won't hit you
but just know I love that Nick has never
spoken confidently of his by skills
except for a gift I can't beat up most
people but my wife I will destroy you
[Music]
all right we're gonna watch this amazing
video uh do you know about Hawker
centers in Malaysia you guys know about
those yeah what what centers Hawker
centers basically like a food court but
every stall is like a different uh owner
so like this place will just have
chicken that place will just it's like
one food like noodles skewers some of
the best stuff ever dude even like
beverages are total different cars it's
very organized yeah it's a lot easier
it's like an OCD Center for food yeah so
I guess what happened in this story is
that These Guys these two guys didn't
get their drink fast enough so they're
complaining and then the owner of that
stall started yelling back at them and
they got into an altercation well they
came back two guys with machetes like
just kill this guy oh whoa and then um
the whole day gets saved when this woman
from another stall she owns a different
stall jumps in and just saves them
no other stuff well she's gangster look
at this wait did she know the Kung Fu
with [__] wushu oh I know what she
did she started nagging me oh
I don't know what I'm looking at dude
she is walking up to him
they're gonna move to the front so you
can see it
oh [__] he's actually trying to kill him
yeah they're trying to straight up kill
the dude what the [__]
and she's Brave as hell it just jumps in
it
oh [__]
well they are not trying to attack her
so yeah they're not they don't want to
hit her I don't have a beep with you
I just want to kill that guy not you
lady feisty bro leave him alone she
saved them too
oh she's holding the guy to wrist yeah
she's really like it's not worth it guys
it's not worth it
don't kill him
oh it's a machete dude
over a drink bro slow service yo and
they're like even though she's grabbing
the wrist they're doing that to her too
and she's not even she's like what she's
not even ducky dude damn do it [__] I
dare you this is who everybody thinks
they are when they comment how come no
one did anything and everyone just stood
there yeah
if y'all didn't do this you don't get to
say that no one does that have you guys
ever seen shanking videos what it's like
the scariest [__] prison shank no no
like just like two people get an
altercation or whatever right and
they're like push and they're like
fighting or whatever then a guy pulls
out a knife and the other guy's like
yeah whatever and then when they just
stab him like a couple of times you just
see the guy like go like what the [__]
and then like literally yeah you're just
like oh my God that's [__] crazy it's
very shock right yeah holy [__] because
there's that video of that Grandma who
had a hatchet in her back or a knife in
her back and she was just shopping like
in the grocery store and then she had no
idea it was there like someone stabbed
her in the back somebody would try to
mug her uh like a few blocks before she
went grocery shopping it was his old
grandma but he had like a big knife and
he stabbed her with it and she was just
walking around shopping just cabbage
whatever and then somebody was like you
have a knife in your back she's like
really oh and then when she noticed it
that's when it started hurting oh maybe
it's the old Asian lady thing they're
just like
shut up lady stop complaining man I just
trying to kill this guy what was said at
the I'm so curious what was said at the
drink spot right just because like
that's such a zero to a 100 and they
don't look like the soda is flat gang
they look like regular people that are
just mad like all Asian people look like
regular people even the gangsters as
good as this is he also runs a Kuma
Where Are You Gonna Get machetes though
you know what I mean like who who just
has machetes with them I feel like all
Asians have machetes to travel through
the jungle yeah if you're a jungle Asian
to cook to travel through the jungle
spank their kids
yeah yeah yeah yeah damn dude that
bravery though to just like um she
didn't step back bro and she's not just
like she's not going like this yeah
she's just like grabbing arms and stuff
but sometimes though I feel like females
are more brave because they have this
man tally of they're not gonna get me
I'm not the target oh like Dana White's
wife yeah yeah
just kidding like okay how many times
have you seen a fight between two six
foot dudes gangsters just [__]
throwing down and there's like the five
foot two girlfriend that comes in in the
middle and goes
lately I've been seeing that girl get
hit a lot yeah I've been seeing those
videos yeah so oh so we just talked but
they get very surprised like I feel like
there's a cultural shift now where guys
are trying to find a reason to Sock up
women now they're just keep it in the
pocket yeah you go out of line enough
because I'm reading these comments it's
scary it's a quality okay yeah I'm re
that's what I'm reading a lot they're
like well you want equal rights equal
fights it's like yeah
it's equal fights so I I saw this video
good branding too where this girl uh
swung on a dude right like she Swan and
cracked him in the face and this
[__] slapped her so hard her
[__] head spun around dude and then
oh the one at the bar yeah she hit him
and he smacked her back she fell and
then she had a [__] like contemplate
what she just did dude she woke up on
Jupiter she was like what the what
planet am I
slapped her so [__] harsh she went
left frame dude she was out of the frame
and then all the comments and her shoes
are still stuck
she popped out of her [__] shoes the
smoke coming up from the [__] shoes
and then all the comments were equal
rights equal fights like look you don't
ever want to put which I agree you
shouldn't put the way she swung on him
though was like crazy I never socked up
a woman but I understand the sentiment
but the way that I see chicks antagonize
guys over and over and over and over and
over and over and then they swing if the
dude just does like one backhand thing
I'm like I kind of deserved it man I
feel like a lot of guys have felt this
way right like I don't I believe that
you could walk away from a situation
because at the end of the day the end
result is that you can murder her if you
want that Steve Green's remember Steve
Green said that we were like oh I didn't
think of that you said something like no
that's because he hasn't seen a lot of
fights that's because yeah he has never
been married to jio
I've seen chicks straight [__] dudes up
in high school oh so like I'm like he
he's seen like this much of that world
so it's different you know I told my
girl no
she she asked me if I would ever hit her
and I was like I'll give you three
really good hits if you give me three
times then I'll do something that's a
good rule of three yeah it's like
strike one is what she complained too
much no no no no no three hits if she
actually like physically I don't know so
she went one two three and you're like
you still could knock me out [__] pow
is it is it like hits in succession or
does it reset every fight
she always gets to hit you twice when
they walk away she literally has she
even hit two she'll do it on purpose
what but then she's joking though
she'll smacked me twice and then she's
like I didn't do three yeah
sure
have you guys ever been hit by a girl
that you've been with yes yeah yeah yeah
no not that I've been with so how many
times did you suck her zero oh good man
like was she like was it like like like
finger hits or like for like some
damages
I was like saying something it was my
exactly I'm like that's just your feet
slap me across my face but like it was
like half joke but she was actually mad
oh wait what did what happened like I
was making fun of her like something she
that she did I was I was just roasting
her and we were walking and she slapped
me across my face like shut up and she
went like that like hella hard I don't
like that and like there was a split
second of I almost by reaction hit her
back and I just stopped and went what
the [__] just happened yeah yeah whoa
and then I told like a natural reset yo
I was like do that yeah like please
because I have to reflection
it's not a it's just a natural like I
felt like I just needed to do something
I was like whoa that was strange
especially when this gets cocky bro once
it gets cocked it's gonna get let go oh
so how many times have you hit women
yeah whatever actually no I I punch
women before yeah who in the gym like we
sparring oh didn't it feel great yeah I
was like yeah does that feel weird not
when it's the homie that I'm thinking of
her name is Justine why is she hot or
something oh she beat me up she ain't
she oh you talking about the mountain
Korean yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that girl built like a semi truck yeah
which I don't hit her hard but it's just
like but you should like a little flick
of the glass you know she's kind of
tough but yeah she's super tough
techniques that I think is more useful
because you don't have to hit anybody
yeah I tell I always tell Tiff if you
ever hit me like I won't hit I won't hit
you but just know that I will you'll
wake up in El salvage or destroy you
dude
I love that Nick has never spoken
confidently of his Spice Girls except
for again
yeah
I'll be like I can't beat up most people
but my wife I will destroy beat up your
wife that's 80 pounds with sciatica dude
she's in a boot right now I love you but
I will destroy you if you hit me
very weird feeling when somebody of the
opposite sex hits you as if they could
do whatever they want to you that's
weird yeah so like and they keep aching
themselves on over and over so yeah
you've been with somebody who who has
who has hit me before like they swung at
me and they just finished they missed my
face and they hit my arm oh and then I
remember I spell the shell baby and then
I went I went this way
that's what I did and she was like May
weather no so I remember this moment so
she swung at me like she full just swung
at me and it hit my arm and then I did
that right she was nice
Mayweather so I [__] my arm and
everything stopped and I looked at I was
like did you actually just try to swing
at me and she goes like well you're
pissing me off and I looked at her and I
said listen
you have to leave because I feel like I
I'm looking at you like you're a man
right now oh and there's something that
switched in my head yeah yeah and I'm
like this will go inside your face now
that I don't view you as like a woman
like I'm that upset I was like either
you have to leave or I have to I'm gonna
fade you up and I'm gonna beat you up
I was like stay in this Barber trash so
I can line you up real quick
zero over the top yeah
hi Paul babe my boy do you like the way
it looks okay you want edges or not and
I brought the mirror I was like looking
from the back too
no but it was like one of those weird
moments where I I looked at her and I
said no now I feel that number one like
I'm not scared of you but I'm scared of
the person that you're making me become
I was like now this relationship doesn't
work because now I'm somebody that I
never wanted to be and I looked at you
like you weren't somebody that was
important to me yeah so I left and I
left for like a few hours and I came
back and I was like listen we're done
now because you don't care well that's
good that you cooled off yeah yeah well
because I would never hit a woman just
because I mean she's like half my size
but just the thought that I I forgot
that she was a woman and I wanted the
soccer and I was like you guys
discriminate too much actually I have a
question would you ever if a small man
the size of a woman punch you would you
just destroy them or would you do the
same same rule same rule so I oh so
David doesn't discriminate by gender
this is my size and weight it will it's
by because what is the [__] point it
doesn't make me feel good right so for
example there have been times like for
example in K-Town [__] always pops off
right there have been times where drunk
little tiny Korean men will get in your
[__] face because they have like
Napoleon complex right up to your chest
but if I stop this guy right what
happens like number one he's drunk he's
not gonna remember he's not gonna
[__] remember this I don't feel good
about this and also too I beat up a guy
that's five foot two you know what I
mean so I just either way I look like an
[__] show the tattoo yeah do you see
what this says I show the tattoo very
differently very sexual
you know what this means fifty dollar
for blow job 100 for the [__] [__] time
but if a guy is like similar in size
then it's then it's no holds bar because
now there's like an even chance of both
of us getting knocked out it doesn't
[__] matter and by the way I don't
fight people like that like I don't I
don't do that most likely I just step
away because when you're older you can
lose everything yeah right when you're
younger you don't care as much
especially when you're broke you have
absolutely nothing now I'm married I
have a wife yeah I have a business
problems yeah especially with this guy
you know like I everything and aren't
you in charge of marketing we might even
get more sales if you get into a fight
on the street just saying plus the
Waikiki Davis so punch
you're like a circus freak step right up
and suck David's soul
yeah but there's like there's no the
white Kiki yeah the payoff is stupid and
the thing about it is too and I really
just thought about this just for
watching these videos that I started to
realize through other people's comments
everybody has an ideal version of sales
until they're in that situation yeah of
course yeah everybody talks themselves
up so big and we're all guilty of that
right so when we say things like when we
see like for example the bystander stuff
why didn't anybody say anything yeah
you're always the best version of
yourself before you put yourself in that
situation I've seen people get robbed
and I just watched like literally
outside of a Jamba Juice I saw a guy get
robbed and I just looked at him I was
like this is interesting because you're
probably just registering what's
happening too yeah it's that bystander
[__] whatever and the person left and I
went
[Laughter]
it was like normalcy biased that's what
it's called like you don't know what's
happening and I'm just watching it like
this is bad dude somebody's getting
locked and the cop taking the reports
like what what what
stop what
he's like I'm doing the report
what are you screaming for oh I just I
just defended them it happened three
hours ago I was defending them through
time yeah but everybody's tough [__]
until you're in that situation right
even people who are experts and they're
prepared for that situation still don't
know
unless you're the Detroit defense guy
yeah he knows
right now I'll show you how to do it
[Laughter]
[Music]